by the case it's having to decide and by
the limitations placed on it by the
Supreme Court
and they
implication the outcome
that we face is that no British child
who has been trafficked outside the UK
will be protected so by the British
state if the Home Secretary invokes
National Security
I think you would like to say a number
of things Daniel but we have a number of
collective things to remind you of when
you read the judgment
I think what what really jumps out of
the judgment is what the commission
didn't say what they didn't do is
endorse what saja Javid said in
September 2021 he said you haven't seen
what I saw if you did know what I knew
you were sensible responsible people you
would have made exactly the same
decision of that if I have no doubt in
fact this commission which saw exactly
the same material that Sergeant saw
didn't say anything like that at all he
described the case as finely balanced
and said that reasonable people might
strongly and profoundly disagree with
what with the way in which was
so I do you want to say anything more
about trafficking
I think
we've been judgment the
parents a credible suspicion
this traffic a credible suspicion that
she was harbored by the traffickers
until 2019 a credible suspicion that
there are extraordinary failures
within the UK in preventing her failing
to prevent her and her friends traveling
reading the factual underpinning of what
commission considers to be made out on
Miss Pagan's behalf you would feel that
there will be no way that she could not
have succeeded in her appeal but you
will equally see repeated as a thread
through the Judgment how the commission
invokes the Supreme Court's view that
its role was limited and it cannot
consider the merits of a case it's
limited to the most narrow grounds of
administrative review
in consequence you have a judgment in
which the court is effectively saying
as things stands now we are stuck in a
way that we do not think reflects the
findings we are making
so uh that's basically it I mean in
terms of the legal fight that's that's
nowhere near over we're not going to go
into details about exactly what that
means at this stage I think what what
else this judgment calls out for though
is um some some courage and some
leadership from the Home Secretary to
look at this case of fresh in light of
the clear and compelling factual
findings that this court has made thank
you
we're going to challenge the decision
but we're not going to go into further
deals no limit to the challenges but in
our view they include the government
taking on responsibility of conducting
its own review
what Prospectors
any reaction from her family about her
decision today you've known before
they've known she will have known as
you've broadcasted and so we'll be
speaking speaking to those we can speak
to immediately now immediately she
wasn't allowed to know the outcome until
10 am today and neither was uh so well
thank you very much